اكثر من 100 جزيره تتوسط نهر النيل في
شمال السودان هذه الجزر الكثير وتعني
باللغه النوبيه الطريقه الضيق
هذا الجمال الطبيعي الخلاب بقي مهملا حيث
لا بنيه تحتيه تجذب السياح
لمساكن لائقه ولا خدمه بل لا يكد الناس
يعرفون شيئا عن هذه المعالم السياحيه
من المعلقات ما عندنا عبارات او ما عندنا
العشيات او حتى ما في فنادق على اساس انه
يضيف فيها السايح المده اللي هو عايزه
برده من من المعلومات برده الكهرباء
يبلغ عدد سكان الجزر السياحيه نحو سبعه
الاف نسمه يمارسون زراعه بشكل تقليدي
ينتجون الفوله والفاصوليا والبرسيما وبعض
الخضروات يشعرون انهم في عزله عما تقدمه
الحياه الحديثه من خدمه
لكن لو كان في دعم من الحكومه وكان الناس
بتستفيد يعني
ممكن تستفيد اكثر
ياهو نحن استعبط الطويريه والمنجل ما في
تحولت جزر الكاسينغر شماليه السودان الى
ما يشبه الجزر المعزوله بسبب غياب الخدمات
الحكوميه وضعف البنى التحتيه رغم ان هذه
الجزر تمثل ثروه قوميه باعتبارها مناطق
جذب سياحي
وغير بعيد عن نهر النيل وفي مساحه شاسعه
اكتشف الباحثون في مجال الاثار غابه
متحجره
جذوع وفروع وبعض ثمار كلها متحيره وتعود
الى ملايين سنين لكن اهمال البحث العلمي
جعلها مجرد حجاره ملقاه على الارض
بعد اذنك
في الوصول الى هذا المكان لعدم وجود شواهد
على الطريق
هل رايت سيارتكم كان هذا المكان يعج
بالاشجار في سابق العهود من المهم توفير
معلومات عن هذا المكان المدهش
يتحسر المهتمون هنا على ضعف الجهود
البحتيه العلميه لكشف اسرار ثروه قويه قد
تحدث ثوره في عالم الاثار
جاري في الشغل
بعض الثمار
[موسيقى]
البدريه حق هنا لكن نوع من الفواكه كله
حجر في شمال السودان تحته كنز وقصه على
الارجح ربما يكشف الوصول الى حقيقتها ما
لم يخطر على بالي باحثين في علم الاثار
الطاهر المرضي الجزيره من الولايات
الشماليه الكرو